can everybody hear me cool I've never
used to mic like this before it's
exciting I feel like a radio announcer
as someone said to talk like you're a
radio announcer yeah so morning everyone
thank you for the introduction as Mac
said my name is Michelle Tortola I am a
software engineer at square over in San
Francisco has everyone here know what
square is okay good I'm not gonna do a
demo or picture I wasn't going to anyway
anyway as you heard in my bio I have
quite a colored history so I first
started out doing consulting primarily
in mobile but also in sort of API
development specifically around mobile
apps I then went full mobile for a
couple of years and now I do back-end so
over the course of my career I've been
dealing with api's from both sides I
spent a long long time primarily
consuming them and now as a back in
engineer I'm writing them so the focus
of this talk is what do api consumers
care about you hear a lot of talks that
are like build your api is this way
build your API is that way but I
specifically want to think about how
someone using your API is going to
evaluate it to give you some tools so
that the next time you're building out
an API you can think like the person on
the other side so and I'm going to
totally spoil the talk right now and
tell you exactly what they care about
and then we're gonna go into details so
they care about documentation what your
URL structure is going to be like what
your payloads are like authentication
authentication and authorization they're
different error handling and caching and
this is a very very small subset of the
things that people care about there's
obvious a lot obviously a lot more but
over the course of the talk I'll be
sharing some fun stories that have to
deal with all of these areas because
I've seen some things so let's get
started so documentation good
documentation exists that was a joke and
it's true I don't know how many times I
tried integrating with someone's API and
they'd like link me to the source code
that's useless
especially I started my career knowing
PHP and then I went into objective-c if
you were gonna send me into Ruby or Java
I would have absolutely no idea what was
going on so you need to have an artifact
or something so that people can read
along and then reference it as they're
debugging seeing weird things bonus is
its interactive the tooling around
interactive documentation and generation
has gotten really really great some of
you are probably thinking I don't want
to like write some webpage to do this
there's tooling for it so if you're not
familiar with the open API specification
or any of the other tools available that
let you document your api's and a
computer computer readable format I
highly recommend you use it because then
you get stuff like this for free so this
is a library that read redock is a
library that reads a open API
specifications and will generate static
HTML CSS JavaScript for you it takes all
of the information puts it on a webpage
you can put it wherever the heck you
want and it has an interactive console
which is the most important part because
the first thing I do is I consumer API
is try it out and if I don't have to
write any code to try out your API it's
gonna be a lot better and then you can
also do things like if you're debugging
you can just send someone a payload and
be like try this in the documentation
and tell me what happens instead of
having to like walk over open a console
run something locally but then the other
person needs to set it up locally it's a
huge pain so having a place like this
makes coordinating and communicating
really really great the bad
documentation that isn't up to date this
happens a lot so back in my consulting
days I would be working with companies
who are building out the first version
of their mobile app and for a lot of
those companies this was also the first
version of their API because obviously
mobile apps need api's to work so we
would be iterating really fast working
really closely together and then
something would ship to production but
then we wouldn't update the
documentation so then it'd be kind of
difficult to keep up or you'd say oh
this was last updated two weeks ago what
the latest version has anything changed
and you'd have to go and talk to a
person every single time again slows
things down it interrupts developers who
don't like being interrupted and it's
just not a great experience so the ugly
documentation again this goes back to
people who think API documentation as
code does not exist or people who think
they can just like write prose and tell
you about their document to tell you
about their API and pros like forma
that's not not great I want code samples
I want payload examples I want all of
those really great things so usually
this is my reaction you keep using that
word documentation I do not think it
means what you think it means
and again happened to me it's fun so
let's talk about URLs
now I'm specifically calling out URLs
here because it's a consumer of api's I
like writing code as few times as
possible so if I can write some helpers
to automatically generate URLs for me
I'm going to which is why they're so
important so good URLs have consistency
you would probably expect this rest is
the thing now I don't necessarily have
to explain rest anymore I've given this
talk quite a few times I used to have to
explain rest now I don't so having
things that are consistent where you
know what the different parts of the
path mean you know what the identifier
is mean just as someone with developer
common sense I can understand what these
different URLs are doing so if you're
going to have a restful api follow
restful conventions if you're having a
different paradigm if you're going with
something like Jerry PC your graph QL or
any of that stuff again follow what
their conventions have been established
the bad inconsistency I see this so
often when working with API is that were
developed one off for all of these
different projects and I'll talk about
this a lot because when companies build
their first version of their mobile app
they're usually starting to use some
api's that were built for JavaScript
front ends they're not necessarily the
same those and
were built one-off in time by various
different teams so tend to be
inconsistent so you get things like oh
these all look consistent but then you
get these weird things where the last ID
in the path is not actually related to
the object that came before it I've seen
this done as an optimization for like
instead of having like four or five
nested things you can do this one super
special thing and then it you don't have
a really long URL it's really really
hard to debug it's hard to understand
and you're going to forget about it to
be perfectly honest
so the ugly send get to slash remove to
delete something I did this it's not a
joke
you're not following standard HTTP
semantics and you're not following
built-in caching semantics because a lot
of client libraries make assumptions
about gets versus deletes so then you
really just want to run away because
this is really really bad please don't
do it
we had to debug a whole bunch of
problems because of this we eventually
got them to change it turned out they
had some weird firewall rules they
couldn't send deletes so they update
their firewall
in order to send a delete request
because technology is hard okay
payloads good things about payloads you
have all of your data one of the biggest
problems that I ran into when I was
working in mobile is that you had to use
sometimes four or five different
endpoints to get all of the data for a
single screen and then as the
client-side developer I have to be like
okay I have five endpoints what if one
of them fails are any of them dependent
on each other and then you get into
these weird States for like maybe I can
get the really big product images but I
can't show the price on an e-commerce
app that's like a really bad experience
so you want to make sure that the api's
you're building have all of the
information and if you're starting to
see requests come in like three or four
at the same time hopefully you have some
good tooling around that you might want
to think about combining those because I
think we've gone past the days of like
only ever write generic api's you also
want to be able to write api's that are
custom for the experiences that you want
to create your payload should also
respect the content type I'll get into a
little bit about why later but if you're
ever sending something back that wasn't
the same content type it causes problems
and versioning so in my experience
payloads are the things that should be
versioned not necess urls are easy to
change those are you know not a problem
but as soon as you make a breaking
change change to your payload that's
when you want a version because some
clients consuming that they're gonna go
look for a field that doesn't exist
maybe it's the price for a product and
it's not going to be there or in the
case of a mobile application the app
might crash
so versioning is not is for payloads not
necessarily for other things so the bad
ok story time I've worked on a lot of
e-commerce apps like probably about five
of them now and one of our clients we
were building out the first version of
their app they had a JavaScript
front-end single page app this was back
in like 2014 I don't remember what
framework they're using but I'm pretty
sure it's dead now and so they built out
some new endpoints for the app but in a
lot of instances we were reusing
endpoints that have been built for this
JavaScript front-end so for instance
there were a bunch of different ways to
get product information you could get a
list of products you could get
individual details of products and you
can also see some product information in
the cart now what happened is because
these api's were developed mostly
organically over time is we had a hard
time figuring out what the Product ID
was and and this is an abbreviated list
there are actually seven of these and
some of them actually returned the
product ID in two different fields and I
had to write code to handle this because
we were doing you know good
object-oriented programming we don't
want to pass around just random like
hashes or dictionaries we wanted an
object so you had to write a parser it
was a pain and this was actually in a
whiteboard in the conference room we
were working in because no one could
keep it straight it was not great so be
consistent and even when you're creating
those things
one off api's you do want to start
establishing conventions for things do
you want to use the ID field what
happens if you have nested products like
in the cart where you have a cart item
with like quantity and like a SKU number
maybe but then you actually have like a
subset of product details with like a
little picture and the name you need to
figure that stuff out early otherwise
you're gonna write code that deals with
this and it's really not great code the
other thing about payloads is dealing
with change so as I said I worked a lot
with teams who are building out API is
basically as fast as we could use them
and so things were changing left and
right so we expect certain things if
you're looking through a piece of
documentation even if it's just really
basic you're going to make assumptions
about what you see like image URLs
having HTTP in them this actually became
a problem for us because way back when
SSL was not as ubiquitous on the web so
the team was working to add us a cell to
the full website and they decided to
take out HTTP colon slash slash from all
of the image URLs they passed back
through the API so that depending on
whether you on HTTP or not you could use
the right beginning but they didn't tell
us and we had a board demo that morning
so we're our I was on in the room
thankfully I heard about this later cuz
I had a debug it but they were doing
board demo and all of a sudden things
were looking great things looking great
they get to one specific page because
they'd only done those to one API which
was the product details page and they
couldn't load any pictures in front of
the board it was really bad it made us
look bad it made everyone else look bad
so even by having some really simple
assumptions you want to make sure that
those don't change another thing that
happened a different company they were
expanding into different AWS regions and
so they're different machines didn't
have time zones they were now in
different time zones they wanted to add
time zones to all the dates guess what
you hard code in most client-side
applications date person you can't get
that from
server usually so again it causes a
crasher they had to roll it back and
then we had to figure out what was the
time the one and only true timestamp
forum format we were going to use for
everything because trust me you do not
want to deal with four five six
different ways of parsing timestamps
depending on what end point you're using
again it's really not fun code to write
it's not fun code to maintain and it
leads to a lot of books so as consumers
of API is when it comes to payloads we
expect certain things to not change so
when you're writing your documentation
if you have an example date if you have
an example URL people are going to
assume that that's what it's going to be
unless you say otherwise the ugly this
is where we get into some fun stuff JSON
containing HTML this was actually a bug
way back when and linked rails two or
three where if you requested JSON and it
had some sort of internal server error
it would return an HTML page sometimes
as JSON sometimes as not it was it was a
massive pain and as a client-side
application our JSON parsing would fail
sometimes we would crash if we weren't
handling the error and sometimes it
would just have a blank screen which is
obviously a really bad experience I also
asked on Twitter a couple years ago so
this one is how about an XML response
containing one element in which there
lurks the real XML document as an
escaped string I've also seen this done
with JSON though also again for those
JavaScript front ends because I know
there's some interesting semantics
around error handling with the HTTP
status codes again really really not fun
to deal with I mostly think that people
do this they want to do it really fast
but then as a consuming developer I'm
like you're just trolling me and again
going back to the stability of your API
is there's nothing more frustrating than
dealing with an unstable API because you
can have everything working beautifully
one day and then the next day you come
in and everything's going wrong and you
have no idea what just happened
you're like my code didn't change and it
wastes developer cycles it means more
communication more
overhead and generally is just a worse
experience for everyone okay
authentication good SSL if you're not
using SSL please use SSL the first few
times they gave this talk SSL wasn't as
easy to get you still had to pay those
like ridiculously priced certificates
but now you can do it for free so please
use it but make sure it's secure
security is a really big thing when it
comes to authentication and
authorization and have your bases
covered who remembers goto fail only a
couple hands so this was a bug in on iOS
and Mac a couple years ago where in
certain conditions it would actually
bypass SSL certificate verification on
the client-side so that means anyone
could have man in the middle all of your
stuff and it would have been totally
fine which is why you have to care not
just about where your code lives and
where your servers are and what your
firewalls are doing or what browser or
what iOS or a mobile version that the
person on the other end is using you
have to worry about everything
in-between
which is why SSL pinning if you have if
you're working with mobile clients use
SSL pinning it's just two-way make sure
that both are agree that they are who
they say they are instead of just a one
way it really really helps the security
and it's a lot easier to do now than it
was a couple years ago and then of
course use an open standard something
like Oh F to actually authenticate your
users so authentication is in some ways
about if you're dealing with mobile you
have to identify the mobile client if
you're in a browser you just
authenticate the user and hope that the
browser is okay well not hope but try to
do a little better the bad also OAuth
again lovely friend from Twitter can you
have a slide that says Oh F and leave it
up there for 45 minutes
Olaf is very controversial but it is an
open standard and you want to use
standards because when we get to the
ugly you can become Bob the Builder and
then build everything yourself and then
guess what
there's no tutorials on how this works
you can't look things up on Stack
Overflow
there's no videos there's no conference
talks it's completely homegrown which
means your developers are gonna heart
you know they might build it once but
then if they need to support it ongoing
it's just gonna be a pain and you're
also going to expose yourself to
vulnerabilities that the community would
have fixed one of my co-workers and
InfoSec puts it as you are a zebra and
everyone else in the Serengeti is a lion
if you rely too much on your own code so
authorization which I'm gonna say is
different than authentication
authentication is who are you
authorization is what are you allowed to
do and there's a very important reason
why you separate these two so for good
Offutt authorization you want whatever
your client-side application is to
request permissions to do things you
want to be very explicit and what it can
do especially because chances are when
you're building out your API is you're
like oh get post put post delete done
right you have all of them they're just
available but sometimes you don't want
people deleting I actually really love
the Google Cloud API is because they
have explicit watt scopes for literally
doing everything and by using this what
you can do is say you have an admin
level credential if you authenticate and
say this instance of this credential is
only allowed to read someone gets ahold
of that credential that let token
they're not going to be able to write
they're not going to be able to delete
so it significantly reduces the attack
vector in case you're compromised in
some way so the bad a single API key
yeah this is super super popular and I'm
really glad to see that some of the
major API providers are moving away from
it and you're probably wondering
everybody does this why is it so bad
well first of all that API key is
compromised guess what you need to
change it there is a day for mobile on
Apple Store where it took ten days to
get a new version out can you imagine
your users
ten days to use your application now
they're just gonna delete it unless
you're like you know super important
like their financial app or messages or
something but for most of us it's like
end-of-life er the product if that
happens but you also have to deal with
things that can get a little hairy like
you could end up rate limiting
yourselves this also happens to me in
production app got featured on Apple's
home page tons of downloads and we
exceeded ourselves at rate limit and it
took at least an hour for the app to
recover all because we were using a
single API key instead of having a more
robust solution to handle this I also
when I was researching the redock
example they used gif ease API and the
API key there is also like permanently
great limited from giffy which i thought
was hilarious so you can do all sorts of
crazy things with API keys the ugly
authorization if you're only doing
authentication and you're giving users
full read/write access to everything
things are going to eventually go wrong
I've worked at companies where third
parties reverse engineered our API is
from the mobile apps because they
weren't public and then just started
using them you don't want that to happen
to you you don't want some malicious not
necessarily malicious but just curious
even third parties using what you built
without your permission especially
because you're gonna have to pay for the
server costs you're gonna have to pay
for all of the increased traffic you're
gonna have to deal with what happens
when they accidentally you know DDoS
your server but it's an API that only
the app uses so how could that happen
a lot of people also don't think about
authorization when it comes to mobile
because they think it's super secure you
can totally trust Apple and Google to
have the most secure things ever but
there are proxies there are people who
set up bogus Wi-Fi networks Charles is
the aid to buckin proxy that we
frequently used in mobile because you
just wanted to see what was happening
especially if you're dealing with like a
third-party SDK you want to see what was
happening it's also like
you can google it and there's a whole
bunch of information out there how to do
it so you can't always assume that just
because you're using a vendor for
something or a provider that has a
low-level framework that it's going to
be secure and just keep track of
everything for you you still need to
care errors everybody loves the unhappy
path so good using proper HTTP error
status codes they're great people can
make assumptions about them that they
don't have to revisit and recode and
write all these exceptions for a really
great thing is to have an error message
in a response for a developer so they
know exactly what went wrong instead of
them having to guess the worst thing to
do is still have like a blob of JSON
that you sent and then the example blob
of JSON and then you're just going key
by key and figuring out which key is
incorrect again I've done it and once
you get JSON blobs that are like you
know 70 a hundred keys in them which you
can it's it's painful but you also want
a human readable error message because
at some point if this is important
enough it's gonna be affecting the users
experience so you want to make sure that
they're having the best experience
possible say oh hey we can't load this
right now and why is that Michelle and
that's because you don't want to have a
single generic error message that just
pops up all the time it's true I had an
app that did this they made the decision
every time we get an error just showing
alert
oops something's amiss you'd be like
scrolling through lists and like
randomly this alert would pop up and
you're like but what's wrong everything
on the page looks fine did I do
something wrong what what should I do
it becomes incredibly confusing so don't
have super generic error messages you
also don't want api's that return a 200
but then have an error in the body I
know that there are some JavaScript web
frameworks that have you know some
semantics around this but if you're not
dealing with that if it's not required
make sure you're using your proper
status codes because as a
consumer of your API is if I got a 200 I
think everything's great I think
everything's actually okay
and I don't have to like dig in and find
some random error thing that you threw
in there and let's get to the ugly as I
mentioned API is can return HTML pages
on air instead of JSON gotta love
sending HTML to JSON parsers that works
great for or for pages that return 200
in HTML instead of JSON again respecting
content type respecting HTTP status
codes because these are really simple
things that can make the consumers of
your API have a much better experience
in integrating with your API when you
don't it kind of goes a little bit off
yeah it gets a little weird so caching
what is good to cache well we have
standards
there are several standards and several
different ways to do caching and why is
caching important well your app might be
on the front page of Apple's App Store
one day and you go from having a couple
hundred users to thousands in the span
of a couple hours you want that stuff to
be cached so you can do you can use the
cache control header which lets you set
all sorts of information how long
something should be cached what is the
max age that something could be how
could have or you could say don't cache
which you're going to want to do on some
of your endpoints you can you send an if
modified since header and say hey only
give me new information and if it hasn't
been modified since yesterday and then
HTTP most of the good clients out there
will return a specific 8 status code so
you can handle that separately from the
rest of your cases if you want to you
can also use etags etags are these
little tokens that you can save and then
send back and saying only give me new
information if this new information is
available after this tag it's just a
token based way of doing the same thing
so the bad
manually processing your data every
single time you shouldn't necessarily be
going to a database to return
information that hasn't changed
caches are really great the caching
technology has evolved in so many
amazing ways and it is cheaper and
easier than ever to just add a caching
layer in front of it you will need to
tune it but manually processing every
time also means your api's are faster so
everyone gets a better experience your
servers have less load and your end
users get to see their information a lot
quicker the ugly caching I don't care
again I've heard this they're like Oh
our servers can handle it just fine and
I'm like but some of your requests take
1 or 2 seconds no one wants to deal with
that and that's like me being on good
office Wi-Fi not driving through the
middle of nowhere going from cell tower
to cell tower and like my service
constantly dropping which we always talk
about in mobile the tunnel problem which
is what happens when a user is using
your app not while driving but as a
passenger and yes that's a very
important distinction to make when I
give this example so someone's using the
app in a car goes into a tunnel and then
you have no service but like the app was
doing things how do you handle that
caching helps with that and you need to
so if you have locally available data
that you know you can use your device
will cache it locally if you set one of
those headers and if you don't do
caching it just causes lots of headaches
but you do need to do caching correctly
you don't want to be serving old data
you you know I've seen some really
interesting bugs on servers where one of
the caches was configured incorrectly so
it's not the easiest thing but
definitely think about it so to sum up
everything we've talked about when
people are consuming your API is they
want consistency they want to be able to
quickly scan over your documentation
they want to understand the patterns
that you're using and that you've
established they
want to understand what are the
conventions that you've established and
to see if you're using established
conventions from the rest of the
development so conventions and you also
want to keep your API simple you don't
want people guessing you don't want
people second guessing you don't want
people having to bug another member of a
team every time they have a question
because oh hey this is a little weird I
don't quite understand it so by keeping
your API is as simple as possible and
tailored when you can you'll have a much
better experience with consumers of your
APs and that's all I got thank you
[Applause]
yes I have I'm sorry so I had to I have
had to do this before and we started by
trying to use a standard first of all
simply because if you don't have
anything to start from other than what
already exists if you can build to open
API spec or ramble or any of the other
those are the two most popular standards
now but any of the ones you'll get a
whole bunch of tooling for free but then
it's honestly really just exercising the
API it's going through seeing what
examples you can find if you have source
code that uses that API that is a really
great place to start because then you
can start seeing all of the little
nuances like Oh are they sending this
number as a string sometimes in some
ways or sending it as a number and the
other I've worked a lot with e-commerce
and financial applications and so we
always work in cents instead of in
dollars because floating point math is
horrible so like little you'll start to
learn little things like that as well as
start figuring out those inconsistencies
that table I showed with the different
product end points all of those end
points Atari existed didn't have
documentation so we were going through
and documenting them as we went along
simply because like we needed to use
them other teams needed to use them and
the ownership of api's will change as
your organization grows too so those are
kind of be my recommendations it is a
lot of like trial and error if you
haven't used a tool like postman it lets
you make API calls locally on your
machine there's other there's also paw
for Mac which does the same thing so
it's just like a basically an HTTP
client as a GUI so you can just plug in
and play around with things there that
works really well too
I'm a big fan of path versioning simply
because every time I'm like as a
back-end developer looking at my logs
you'll have the path name printed as a
client developer looking at my logs
you'll have the path name printed it's
kind of like if you're going to only log
one or two things about our requests
it's going to include the path name
sometimes you might have headers at
square we are a financial company so we
actually have redactions and a lot of
our logs and they cover ten digit
numbers for instance so sometimes it
gets a little hairy if you are trying to
like rely on payloads because that's
going to be a little bit heavier
redaction I've also seen what works well
is date versioning as well so but that's
a lot more work to support so if you
ever want to make a change you're like I
want the API as of June 1st 2018 then
you as the developer need to own that so
I do suggest paths we can debate later
if anyone has other opinions ok can I
don't know where you are
oh I'll I spent six months at my last
job building a tool that did this they
didn't open-source it unfortunately
before I left it's kind of difficult so
they like the if you're dealing with
those kinds of issues between changes or
between like deploys for instance like
you're working with a an API team the
API team is moving really really fast
they're moving stuff around the best
thing you can do and I've also done this
is have like a Jenkins job or something
that hits the API and just validates the
format like if you can't tie it to the
deploy fine but just have it hit it like
every four hours and like a staging
environment or something just so you can
kind of get notified of those changes
beforehand so you can come in
you know Monday morning and see that Oh
someone deployed late Friday night and
my little test says that the format's
changed and you don't need to use any of
the formats for that if you do use open
API spec or Ram all you can do
validation against the documentation but
you can also just write it yourself if
it's like business-critical
just be like I expect the structure to
look like this and then just kind of run
it but it is kind of a manual process up
until you have a more up until your API
team has a more robust test
infrastructure that will find those
changes ahead of time but also work with
them on actually establishing a contract
it's natural for api's to evolve over
the course of development but you want
to really start nailing down that
contract as soon as you have a really
good idea of what it's going to be
otherwise you're just gonna keep doing
this and then once it gets into the wild
it's gonna break things
hmm robust API test framework so I've
experimented a little bit with pact PA
CT it is a two way test framework so it
involves both the client and the
producer of the API is and that they
both basically agree on a contract and
as part of your integration tests they
both run it's a little complicated to
set up but I've seen it running and it
does help with that like tracking
changes problem so that's kind of the
only one I've used other than just like
kind of doing it myself with manual yeah
a lot of the comes down to the user
experience so one of the e-commerce apps
I worked on had a separate end point for
product details and reviews you could
get like the star rating from the
product details call but otherwise if
you wanted like any reviews that was a
separate endpoint and so it would be a
really weird experience and we ended up
moving this into one API because what
would start to happen is the reviews was
a new service so it wasn't as robust it
the API was not as tuned so we'd see all
the product details and then like a list
of start like four out of five and then
no reviews and so it was just a really
poor experience or when you're dealing
with people in really poor network
conditions if you have to make a couple
different calls some of those are going
to fail and then you'll have to start
dealing with a very inconsistent state
that you're showing to your end customer
which again is not necessarily great
especially like with I worked a lot in
e-commerce like you want to make sure
you were seeing like the product and
like the price and like a button that
says add to cart and when it adds to
cart it works so it's more experience
driven rather than performance driven
but with http/2 so who here knows about
some of the differences between HTTP 1.1
and - not okay couple so one of the big
things about HTTP 2 is its ability to
what they call multiplex so right now
with an HTTP connection you kind of can
make one request at a time per
connection it establishes a single
connection but with HTTP 2 it interlaces
things so it has more concurrency
enabled and you can do more things with
it
it's just genuinely a better design so
you can send more data over HTTP 2 but
again you also have to worry about those
connection resets and like if a request
is partially respond
it just makes things a little bit more
complicated so if you're not looking
into HTTP 2 I do suggest doing it it
looks to be a really cool performance
boost it's not necessarily supported
anywhere especially older Android
versions and some of the older browsers
yeah that's a really great question and
I'm heavily skewed I used to do some
work with the open API spec which is
probably why I've talked about it so
much I think their tools are just great
so I think we'll see a lot more tooling
around doing a lot of the kind of API
toil so toils a world word in the sre
your site reliability engineer world
which is like really boring automated
automatable tasks that aren't so like
writing a handler for you know a 404
error like you're you should be able to
write that like maybe once and then you
know reuse it so I think we'll see a
shift of more like Auto being
auto-generate server and client code it
exists today it's not really really
robust but I also think we'll see more
people going the interactive API route
and one thing that I've seen that I
really really like is the ability to
download so I mentioned postman earlier
it's a Google Chrome App / extension
thingy I don't know what they're calling
them these days I've seen companies give
you one of those so that it's not just a
web page excuse me with documentation
you can then load it into your
interactive HTTP GUI and actually play
around with it so I think the Twilio
stuff is really cool really neat but I
think at the end of the day focusing
more on normal developer tools rather
than the cool like it's cool let's let's
be honest it's cool but I think we'll
see more focus on the like more standard
developer tools simply because it's our
bread and butter it's what we know best
we like you know gooeys for certain
things we like command lines for certain
things it's a good information but it's
not net like if you're debugging your
Twilio API integration are you gonna go
play a game are you gonna look at the
documentation you're gonna look at the
documentation oh there's a question all
the way in the back oh there's a mic
Oh for server-to-server so like
basically within your own internal
networks yeah that can work you still
have to worry about if you have an API
key and you're talking to a third party
you still have to worry about what
happens when that API key gets taken
because for especially if you're working
with like a public through party API
there's gonna be some other sort of
public infrastructure between your stuff
in their stuff it's okay
like I know it's it's the standard and a
lot of people do it and we're not
getting rid of it anytime soon but it
does have some inherent risks now if
you're within your own world and you're
using API keys that can work I've also
seen SSL pinning work or if you want to
go really really cool in advance so you
can add something like a service mesh
that handles a lot of that for you at
square we transition to envoy last year
and it's been really great for enforcing
access controls as well it has a whole
bunch of other stuff but it is a much
more advanced piece of infrastructure
than you know a API key you're giving
him a workout
I knew someone was going to ask this
so I Square we use something called sake
it's open-source but you it's very much
our own thing we built it before gr PC
existed which is it's very similar to gr
PC so I'm biased there because I do like
protobufs I think they're they're typed
which is amazing because Jason's not
typed and it's oh my gosh caused me so
much pain in the past cuz it was like is
this number being returned as a number
or a string like it happens all the time
or is this true or in false
actual true or false or in the string
true and false so I'm a big fan of
anything that lets you be much more
explicit so but rest is obviously a
great choice it's super versatile it's
super easy I'm you do have a little bit
more developer complication when it
comes to something like GRE PC and then
I'd say graph QL is even more
complicated so one of my co-workers
Shawnee gal gave a talk at Ruby cocky
about some of the graph kind of about
the graph QL so if we're looking at
doing and graph QL is great if you have
a monolithic database graphic QL is
great if you have a very small amount of
services but if you're trying to get
data from let's say hundreds of services
and you want to do that over graph QL it
becomes incredibly complicated so I
think I'm waiting to see what the
tooling looks like for graph QL as a
consumer of the API is I think is
fantastic I can completely configure my
payload to give me exactly what I want
but there's a very large set-up cost if
you're not starting with it
thank you
[Applause]